foreign
[Music]
what we found was a system-wide failure
to protect women and girls from sexual
exploitation at the hands of Aid workers
in the molokal camp Aid organizations
had known about this for years there was
little done to address the problem there
had been warning signs as early as 2015
and over the years it became so bad that
at least one Aid organization the Danish
Refugee Council criticized other Aid
groups the UN as well as the task force
that was meant to be mitigating this for
not doing enough to address the problem
not taking it seriously and for keeping
victims in the dark about the status of
their investigations documents and
emails also show that that a lot of the
survivors weren't given adequate
adequate care
[Music]
foreign
there was one girl I spoke to who was 15
when she said that she was raped by an
aid worker in the malachal camp she said
that she continued to have sex with him
after she was raped because she he was
giving her some gifts and some money and
she wanted to be able to support her
family after she got pregnant she said
that he abandoned her and then she tried
to kill herself she didn't want to
burden her family with another mouth to
feed
foreign
it's hard getting accurate numbers in
these stories largely because these
cases are underreported people are
scared about of reporting however eight
organizations are also reluctant in many
cases to look into themselves and to
investigate themselves because reporting
abuse can result in Scandal and it can
result in in donors saying that they
don't want to fund groups anymore
[Music]
foreign